hey sup hey
Red Team seven back at it episode four
I'm gonna hit continue cuz I'm really
excited seems to be going well so far
let me pull this up okay sweet was last
thing we did oh you got out to the
camper in the backyard I did I went
outside not only did I go outside but I
found some secrets all around and I
think we're at the point where we're
like going to the mom's house which is
weird why is she living a different
house
well it's it's like the old house but I
think she's just like back in the day
when like um like the dad and the mom
like lived in separate bedrooms and
stuff well it's near the water the pond
or lake or whatever it is I think you're
thinking separate beds like in Christmas
Story sidenote I read the comments we
missed a steroid syringe I could
probably just tell you where it is so
you know we can go get it immediately is
it outside no it's back in the basement
you know the room with the cop hanging
dead you were so distracted by think he
was gonna come alive that apparently
there's a steroid syringe behind a lamp
in there no way I didn't know I thought
there were two in the game I really
looked around I think that's worth going
back for because it permanently
increases your health right that's what
it does I think that's worth if you
wanted to spend five antique coins you
can get a third right now too but you
can also get the faster reload no no you
only need three for the steroids our
engine the camper five for fast reload
nine or something Magnum your math is
correct I think it's worth going back
and because I'm starting with a fresh
story start it seems valuable because
it's
yeah I don't know well yeah cuz you're
gonna go down to the house right now and
you remember meeting goldfish do you
remember so you're in the tunnel right
thank you
you were in the house as Mia being
chased by Marguerite in the VHS tape
that you did remember that and then she
grabbed you in that crawl space but
before she did that she you saw a valve
off to the side right remember that at
all oh you got the new pistol - oh my
god I'm [ __ ] almost dead oh you did
get that stereo so you could use that
right now say heal up and to get more
well you said because I'm on yellow
that's saying you could wait until
you're gonna wait until I'm hurt because
you said it's like an automatic refill
of my life okay so I'm gonna take it
with me though because I have enough
spaces you've a lockpick - okay great I
do oh those are worth like hot monies
and once you get the croaky you can get
that good weapon that we saw in the are
they still in this house like am I still
in severe danger
I wouldn't say bad I don't remember if
Jack still comes after you right now or
not I don't think it does that's a good
question
okay so I might actually need your help
knowing where to go
basement you can go this way right
through here great back in the day we
got it yeah the basement laughter walk
back in there you want to use in there
get two options for the lock think you
can do the lunchbox thing in here the
tool kit or the one up on the outside
balcony in the backyard oh right there's
one in here too the next room over here
as long as nothing comes alive because I
don't have a lot of bullets where is it
in here yeah and the table right there
okay cool
let's do this or no sorry yeah on the
shelf what's that I think you're right
give me something good money money money
worth it okay so whoa
it scared myself alright so now I need
to go to the basement yeah hang a hang a
line all right here you got a problem of
Louie [ __ ] oh my god
I don't like it okay and then down into
the base people seem to like you getting
freaked out when grandma was sitting
right there
oh I did not like her she sucks she's
gross
no no likey um I need your help again
back behind you right now that's good
yeah that's the door you open up the
shortcut I hate this area it's whole
area but do a good job of making you
dread going into the basement oh my god
do they all right right yeah hmm I'm
mentally like I don't even remember no
no I think you need a different key to
go this way you can do that later all
right so this way yeah did I kill
everything I feel like I killed
everything this way yep
really yeah yes yep it's not like a set
number of enemies that you kill it's
usually about like checkpoints hitting
checkpoints when you do a certain thing
Oh guys so much anxiety I he's in here
oh god my little heart
thanks to commenters who told us about
the stereo syringe I played this game
once a half I've never seen it well your
old friend deputy that's on my legs was
that body bag always there no when did
you do that I think it was all right so
Oh apparently it's behind a lamp under
this table or shut up what is that noise
buckets right there how do we not see
that right behind that lamp we were here
we looked wait they said there's a
syringe there where's those that's not
it we're they joking that's a mean joke
no that's not it that looks like a
syringe remember we looked at that yeah
just like jump stand up and look around
see it's just a [ __ ] light I'm very
upset let me look this up I'll be pissed
you got had yeah well sorry for trusting
my fans your fans our fans if they
tricked us they're definitely yours that
would make sense I have the deceitful
fans here we go oh my little baby heart
I don't like this I like got so scared
by my own shadow this whole area is like
too much Oh with a balk this whole area
is just too much for me Mike is looking
it up I'm gonna stab this guy
what the H maybe that's not one or maybe
the people are watching us and actually
thought that looked like a stair it does
look like one but it's not it does but
it's a clamp for the light yes whatever
if you're watching this and we missed it
again put it in the comments and look it
up beforehand so I don't look like you
didn't look it up I just did it doesn't
appear to be a syringe can I go this way
I think give me this snake yeah I could
be wrong yeah I thought there was
another door oh [ __ ] so I just had to go
back now
that's art so either both people were
trolling me or be they thought it was a
syringe and I do know this game as well
as I thought oh my god we got a good
scare out of it Oh whole goddamn section
where am I going in here no stop it's
scary enough it doesn't need anything
okay what could we do let's go to the
mom's house all right ma I got eight
days out okay oh my god everyone a long
way I'm lost I got lost
keep going no you just circled back you
literally just went the full circle no
other way I got laws that way way way no
yes
now right she'll go for that
Gogi okay
a good good way to spend ten minutes
I'll say those always yeah scorpy door I
got lost again
the awesome Jacky shot uh safe super
safe okay so what should I save I think
I should say no you didn't do anything
I got shotgun I was just gonna say that
but yeah you could use that last bullet
in this pistol before you switch to the
better one just quick once you shoot at
this which I'll totally not meet you
just uh you know soaking in the ambience
here it actually looks very nice you
down in that dark water no I don't want
to go in a dark water look at all the
babies get that baby's fertilizer
turn you into baby turn him into
fertilizer it's weird that you just like
can't touch anything
are those open a bull [ __ ] rude trick
what is that go in what is that
that's some kind of beetle that don't
use that bullet I don't like it though
what you got the right idea yeah well
there are you hold it are you pressing
both funds to do the stab yeah is that
not good no it just looks funny
it does look funny you know it hurt Oh
shove into someone's skull easier think
about that a lot
oh [ __ ] the Kish spesh
okay okay okay
and I remember okay what I'm just you
know like we're free of bugs god that's
a big bug bud girl that's a hive
can I stab it
Oh run I've pissed off the bugs stepmom
what do you think I should do find
another way around or something I can't
go near it could I kill it can kill it
with bullets I don't run how much that
guide you right now all right I'll just
lure him this area is interesting you
down in that dog stop saying this oh
she's upstairs don't go up go up that's
kind of funny excellent do you think she
saw it and was like I'm gonna picture
wait hold on sorry that panel on the
wall look different can I
[Music]
you should heal up use that steroids you
know steroids
yes sir I'm not doing well
I mean you would've been fine if you
didn't stop to kill the other bugs well
you know showed him though boom we got
more options and more help so those bugs
are bad student observation thank you hi
whit away look at the map touchpad it is
not shared touchpad correct
remember this layout at all from the VHS
tape
the gallery the room with the puzzle a
bit oh that's creepy my god oh yeah I do
remember this Jimmy that lock Jimmy that
good good like that box isn't anything
right that box wasn't the the X was
there for the door closing um okay so I
remember this section but there's
nothing there
a painting named venomous predator it
depicts a butterfly caught in a web for
pretty soon you'll be that butterfly all
right
okay I don't know what that is such a
thing to light things on fire seems nice
it has the word burner in it so nice
nice nice nice oh I'm almost full here I
could always make more bullets I don't
really need them so checking around can
I look at it yeah how do I do it
accent got it so I need like fuel or I
got it and I can use it how does that
work
read the description it looks like it
can be combined that makes sense
cool what we're doing well so far
creepy swamp also I bet you there's
freaking alligators in this game would
not cuz like the first game did that so
well where it was like every time I
didn't want it to happen you know like
sharks it was like of course sharks and
it's like what do you think of when you
think of like something horrible in a
swamp and it's like you absolutely think
of alligators see this to save room oh
this is nice with a backpack
okay cool
cuz I have a lot of bullets not a lot
but I have a decent amount so I feel
like I don't need it right now and again
make sure you do not reload this pistol
and grab that backpack increase your
inventory size Oh
and then probably save the bobblehead oh
there so this is probably your default
save room for the next hour so I'd say
cool well it depends on what you do
first I'm really excited about this you
have to go back down in the basement
first no I do not not until we find that
snake key yeah I wouldn't go back into
the house until you the snake II or the
croaky the CRO key is the game you have
the pellets for what have a nice round
of croaky alright
well I thought that was a but they do
such a good job with that that tree it
looks like a human these all look like
little people yeah they do that on
purpose that's that's calculated like
this yeah sorry
people can't see what I'm pointing up
but it's like if you look in the
distance pointing it point to it with
your knife nope
that guy as an akai they're all a bunch
of little peeps can they do that purpose
all this is just kind of some of their
cunning and evil ass design well imagine
you were running down the street and say
I'm just go holding a pocket knife like
that thrusting it at random passerby
passers-by maybe that's creepy what it's
like that lady in the bonnet just like
twisted her Exorcist her head around so
I feel like I went everywhere stab me
with this bug hey you let him like hover
to Italian kill him you're never gonna
hit him over here like that
oh they're awful did he injured
got him is Rainbow six siege them around
the corner loophole do not go through
that door just for here I did it fYI now
you're sprinting from those bugs over
hate the bug this also seems like some
kind of bug room did you off the bud Bug
poop it's all the bug poop
okay going to convince I don't want to
use it I want to combine oh my god I put
it in my goddamn safe box I did not even
notice you did that I saw too far it's
really not everybody's fine I tell a
joke on the way okay got a bunch of dead
baby jokes which I don't know that
they're they're definitely not because I
need them remotely appropriate what do
you get when you cross a parrot and a
centipede what a walkie-talkie
how do you get a dead baby out of a
blender oh it won't let me come VIN you
sorry this won't let me come VIN there's
a reason for that
okay so I'm not done yet
it was a good choice to get the burn get
grip a goldfish
oh no bugs oh it's in that cabinet oh
the burner fuel Tenedos oh no lady oh
god what the [ __ ] is that it's bad it
you know like spiders I hate spiders I
don't have a item yeah that sucks like I
don't want to go in there at all
hold up the spiders no I think you can
slice them off with your knife
what in the off chance I'm incorrect
keep your distance while you're swinging
sorry
all right cool next room they jumped at
me
behind you [ __ ] spiders hmm lying in
my nightie but [ __ ] did he try to stab
me and miss no yeah stop moving around
alright I'm telling you you're just
gonna make yourself dizzy you gotta wait
until he's gonna attack daddy stop me
where's he eat this guy stabbed him Mike
oh I love that what do you love to hear
it like we roll around inside it when
you were tilting it you go up that
drawer in the room you just came out if
you want with the lockpick doesn't it
look like an electrical toothbrush in
your inventory the locker metal bay yeah
what drawer right here block oh right
[Music]
well stocked yeah and being very well
makes you wonder if there's some sort of
fight coming up oh my god no there's
more bugs building doesn't look ominous
at all what's that one right there
that's what I'm talking about
I don't really think you can go past
that straight unless you can until you
can deal with that hyah slicing [ __ ] you
well I don't feel great
like a cat
it's building socks
yes
let's get some [ __ ] done well done well
I got that's a good joke the [ __ ] happen
here not not in real life
Oh bugs I'm a broken pinkie and realized
you see that doesn't on it doesn't
unbend more than that without me making
it that's weird
yeah combine that [ __ ] Hey that way oh
it's got 150 already and then I have
another puck yeah pink ribbon how do I
set it on my hotbar do you know sorry go
back are square to move it
items can top the row of your inventory
can be yeah so press square now to move
it and then put it in one of those
spaces
I would say instead of your basic
handgun yeah although you at some point
you want to spend that you didn't do
that I did in Mary go right just press
right I got it square I got it
now right don't you don't suppress there
you go now square X yeah X yeah okay
you're good you're good
we did it we did it everyone okay so
what should I kick oh god what should I
go after first the one that's closest or
the one that pisses me off the most
I would try to conserve it oh you can
like
what [ __ ] they're mad
what do you mean conserve it like I got
two pucks so look look at that hive and
then look past it to where you it would
let you go if you killed it and like you
see if it's worth taking care of right
now no because I can't get there okay so
run like hell you might have to kill
this [ __ ] you oh they're coming
[ __ ] you I got me hey hey hi hi hey
yeah you gotta you got they got me
really good I'm on Yeller hi dad
can I kill these spiders yeah get some
revenge [ __ ] those doors open and
shouldn't be what should I do
I don't either gonna come through the
door they might I think I should just
kill them first okay
kill the hives oh thank you nope nope
nope go back before you waste it look
it's really hard to kill these things
just keep your distance a little more
I'd say okay and also the hive just grew
back because you ran away while it was
damaged get the base of it where's the
base right there that big bulb yes
is that not the [ __ ] bass that's
definitely not the bass did you not
destroy it before no stop run another
fine okay cool
oh wait look up in the corner is that
one no I guess you're fine
I don't know why it came back maybe you
just didn't destroy it all the way sweet
I'm like injured and you got a lot of
first aid all right so I still have 30
things left like it's cool to go in
there but there was other hives should I
kill that [ __ ] you there's two layers to
it I'm out so it's not regenerating you
just didn't kill the second layer I
think it's to combine the burner solid
fuel with chem fluid coat assume yeah
this one yeah I would not waste a strong
carefully are you sure what's the point
using the advanced template right now oh
just dumb I guess I thought you can just
reload oh I like hairspray so you want
me to kill it
god damn bugs inspect this room there's
somebody yeah there's some items not
seeing yes
pucks come on yellow I can't believe
that just cuz of some damn bugs there's
100 right there between those two
combined item Oh bull
what should I do you can make some
burner phew yeah don't do anything yet
unless you need to like you're not
overflowing yet I mean I am I mean like
until you find something need I would
just wait until you see if y-you mean
hell their burner fuel
all right going in
that okay mm-hmm should I save no wait
here Bob stand up and check in there I
hear it too dick can it be above me
could be in another room what was that
you could probably do I would do burner
fuel you think I wanna you need it yeah
and also keep mind you could just not do
anything yet and can remember the
antique coins here or I'll remember it
do you think I'll come back well I mean
even if you don't have to for the main
story you still could for the antique
coin it's not too it's like you're
asking not too far out of your way right
now gone a really long what would that
oh no I want some answers
I always wanted to tell you but I just I
can only remember a little and the rest
is just gone okay well I need that so I
got at least like two more hives to
destroy so you're gonna be more than 60
burner fuel anyway okay and you've
already got a [ __ ] ton of health okay
okay
so I'm gonna combine this with my puck
and then I'm gonna take this and we know
where it goes
check your inventory again see if
there's anything else you could be using
right now or making to get rid of that
to get that antique ownership so if I
use that bullet I get that spot but I
know the guns not gonna disappear oh
just all remember it's there I I knew it
was gonna be there before you came in
here so I have a decent memory if you
have such a good memory what were you
wearing on the last knievel question
a great t-shirt that's just because you
always wear gray yeah I'm furiously
don't look it up
oh god it's saving you know what that
means no I think I was wearing that gray
button I'm sure it I like it was
definitely great though I feel like I
should have a gun does anybody have a
gun please don't be the lady nope
I shot a spider what do I do
yeah yeah I would burn them off in case
you need to loop back a little more if
you didn't get all them up up higher
didn't get all I don't know if I'm using
less or more but I'm just trying to be
really much cooler with it what am i
doing
yeah she's still there what do I you're
avoiding her I would say yeah but I
don't know why she's a deranged
psychopath
no I was I not supposed to do that
no it's the other gun you don't need a
reload um
I can go the other way right yeah you
made a loop by opening that door okay so
say for this way I go back to the save
room if possible outside so you can get
some get your [ __ ] together she's not as
scary as the other guy yet yeah oh [ __ ]
I'm working on it
one more layer on the hive
yeah I'm in labor I heal up you might
I'm injured dude our one son who spied
so in the comments
I don't trust Parliament's anymore right
now but some of the comment said you can
just use an herb to heal yourself a
little bit employed by herb I owe a like
just doesn't do a lot I guess speaking
up there might be still some spiders in
that cage Odie I'm a teensy weensy
spider nice I don't think I can take
those oh I can cuz they stack so you
wanna either go to the safe room well I
got I get rid of that [ __ ] what do I do
let me just circle like you you had her
before you just had to take your time
with that hive so she caught up what's
that noise I mean my advice is to avoid
her right now well just don't know where
she is well you do the puzzle I hear her
clearing her throat were you just hard
this room I heard her tell me here's a
small house I heard her me too of it's a
small house though she could be nearby
without being in the same room
oh [ __ ] there's another goddamn thing no
that's not a hive wait what am i doing
so in which way am I going in the door
yeah that way that left door boys if she
goes outside [ __ ] field that's
alright you actually know I didn't need
to heal I was on green dude we shall
roll with it stop backing away from me
yeah go toward him it's much easier hi
was that a hive on it I don't think
that's a hive on the ceiling although
maybe you're completely right oh [ __ ]
you were right that was a hive my dad oh
no they just follow her that's why there
is one I like we'll figure it out can I
he just shut off Marguerite get to where
I need to go less shrill voice that
she's using
also crouching makes a little bit less
noise sprinting is not okay you probably
do the puzzle right now if you wanna get
rid of that thing well yeah do it do it
remember it freezes time if she oh right
my little baby heart almost a spider
spider fighter flip that with the right
stick I did it nope
I meant
horizontally the right stick
now okay left with the right stick
tweak it a little bit tweak seas
go through there mm-hmm or you can go to
save room talk to you I'm saving I've
accomplished a lot
Hey
I can't bloom antique coin I'll keep in
the back of my mind I can't believe I
accidentally say field you honestly have
so much so many supplies it did don't
worry I don't think you need shotgun
shells you're not even fighting any like
you're fighting flies you need
conventional bullets in general at this
moment well I could just put my shotgun
away that would give me heaps of space
why do you need that much space okay I
think this is enough then or I could get
rid of my gun Mike I don't need this gun
Oh
Marguerite's gross yes she's also
annoying face jack - this whole family
and Lucas they're all just unpleasant
my ex-girlfriends okay she did lure you
here in the first place so I thought she
told me not to come oh yeah good point
she does Oh second safety hole of the
game it's not nearly as safe get out of
my safety hole bugs
I hear her trying to breathe as normal
classic margarita so there's an upstairs
Oh a back door I haven't seen that
before the crew oh it's a crowed [ __ ]
haven't seen that before you tried to
sneak up to the second floor again
didn't you did you think I wouldn't
notice even after what happened to
Evelyn you just keep talking about some
strange medicine what are you planning
to do with my altar you better keep
those sticky fingers off of it nobody
touches my sacred altar I think your
father and I are idiots
we should never been born unforgivably
pathetic always looking down on us and
trying to leave us our home after
everything we've done for you please
stop eating in the microphone that
etiqueta commenter that always calls
home in misophonia i don't care
they're gonna eat her all right all
right
you know the croaky double-headed croaky
what are they flying all these two
headed birds nailed to these doors is
this a way to connect the area Mary I'm
not kidding
I'm sorry that noise and the microphone
is driving me nuts why are you mad at me
it's it's not something I can help
another promise well this is helping
like what I'm doing probably helps in
some way what was that
making me confront it yeah remember this
I do
did she come is that why is she behind
me hey bro secretin bobblehead somewhere
wait psychostimulants did you not pick
him up when you smashed the box yeah
okay cool he's laughing at the hey bro I
mean we all were oh there's a crank
remember from all the other games that
cranks please don't come I don't like
this whole area oh god what's that what
is that lawn mower back here if anything
on it oh no I'm thinking over another
main house yeah it was the main house
headed an empty coin on the lawnmower
what's that noise me it's a bug
no that's [ __ ] I got him by we wily
swinging that's how you do it
crap saving the crank
I feel like I'm gonna die
raise them moss on it left the little
details like that so now you got a
better loop and you don't go back
through the safety hole with all the
centipedes okay I do like that hold uh
yeah okay but I don't have anything that
progressed me in this area yeah you do
the crank I have a crank oh I should go
back to that other place yeah okay
that's why I didn't want you to waste
the burner fuel on that until you had to
crank cuz you can save it all for this
although I guess in the end it doesn't
matter I mean you need it no matter what
but I'm still glad take your mind off it
for a while at least all right but she's
still around right oh I could pick up
that coin you owe me just do it now yeah
and then oh she shouldn't see come on
wait until she leaves the room and then
just go to the right okay [ __ ] idiot
oh you might have been right there
might've been barbecue so wrong about
these bugs in my defense like like I
accepted my incorrectness on the told
you right
just keep that little swarm right there
oh [ __ ] I'm out of goddamn fuel
pop you don't keep going yes
annoying enemy I mean I'm probably doing
it wrong like you're probably supposed
to like
Oh oh [ __ ] wait hold on hold on don't
cross here she's coming why because
she's cornered you where the [ __ ] was
she yeah I guess I don't know toilet
a bobsled gentlemen is a complex machine
yeah so is a toilet hmm can you see if
she's coming she said there was a pool
Runnings quote for the hero wondering
wow there's something in the toilet
uh yeah there's a plastic bag of trash
I'm pointing at it what is the name of
the paper towels it's a toilet upper
okay and it's not paper towels stand
corrected it's a toilet paper what a
weird brand paper towel toilet paper
it's not as good as hey bro window
cleaner
um okay so I have one heel okay so she's
looking for me out there I think give
the door a little crack a little peek
you see her in the air I saw her might
not be the best time to go in there I
guess she's right there
shy go away can she come in here I don't
know cuz I didn't know Helen he could
still see her in the window which window
she just walked past that one on the
right of the lantern she won't go
outside will she I don't think so oh
she's going back to the right okay so I
just say because she's going toward the
save room just use the croaky and worry
about saving we're back toward across
that first draw bed you rose [ __ ] this
thing's gonna keep [ __ ] [ __ ] up
flame it if you want you have enough I
know I don't so I just gotta run even hi
yeah you're right um I guess so yeah
yeah just keep running you're fine yeah
where's the croaky straight across the
bridge from here
croaky be on the lookout for her though
yeah up there but the lightest right
you don't think I should save I think
it's autosave the Gators Oh the goddamn
Gators get it gonna shoot her
yeah but don't waste it wait until ya
wait until she's like well she said it
bugs gonna plant their album I don't get
a hunger too much you're gonna reload
we don't really blame her yeah am i
hurting right yeah I'm only at 28 I
would get a gun shooter sooner so you
know the worry about the be smaller bugs
to fur wait why wait yeah [ __ ] you shy
shooters job no oh that a double bug
kill with a knife we play yeah that was
lucky though but totally on purpose
oh god I can't believe it she was
leaking like death so actually here's
what uh hello now save um no I feel like
I should save okay you don't think I
should say no no you can say but you can
go through the door behind you but the
kuroky also gives you access to the
other room in the fireplace drawing room
where you got the first steroid syringe
cheeps can't get their cool
I don't know where I am and I got I've
been here
I played one part a little fetus [ __ ]
sorry I fire alarms been going off all
day on accident or are you guys having
fires all day okay so oh here we gonna
read this series serum the following
items to synthesize serum d series
cranial nerve d series preferable
peripheral prefer for the preferable
nerve cranial and peripheral I think
that's it now I just need to eat this
fetus and we got it I'm not eating that
videos what little creatures though like
to write it down with those strings so
that it wouldn't be able to move what
little creatures why does that be a
little crick little ants like nailed him
down huh how could a human not have done
that the thing wasn't just sealed all
the time you open it without online okay
[Music]
well did he find a serum I just got done
dealing with your mom and her [ __ ]
bugs what you could have warned me sorry
about that what about the serum I
haven't found any but I did find out we
need to make one a d-series head and an
arm this can't be right a head I think I
have that around here somewhere you do I
don't know about the on though have you
searched the whole house no not yet I
still need to check the second floor
here all right check it out meet me at
the trail if you find it
ladies gonna double-cross me Oh save it
save what the game so you're you're
saying don't go any further is there a
safe room in here no but it's not too
far for me downstairs
why wouldn't I done that before you said
you were going to you then just never
did well you were like I mean it's but I
would say that okay might be a good time
down in the episode actually there's an
hour
where's the safe room again I forgot and
then outside mmm it's more is she still
here or I killed her and she won't come
back that's a very loaded question she's
not here
damn you he's making me think there's
something there but it's Bob hmm wait
yes sorry I like mentally give forget
which way I go nice you gonna rock done
there's one more thing before we end I
want to see okay let's go back toward
the attic where you just came from mhm
that's what I wanted to do
I'm gonna put this coin away because I
don't need it do do I need that crank
I'll keep it just in case no you you're
sure all right let's just go and
investigate a couple things in the Attic
oh [ __ ] bugs they're awful Oh bug
light sorry oh hey where you going go
back I got I got lost again yep I guess
I was right making me second-guess
myself so I go through those bugs yeah I
guess you did that on purpose
mommy get wrong bugged now go look down
that hole what hole her hole where she
died yeah just
okay it's just a bunch of bugs right
yeah it's gonna be a bug I just didn't
know if you kind of noticed what she had
turn into blood sweet alright go up to
the attic next episode oh we got the
crow key you can get the another weapon
well let's go in here for no this is a
while
what do you mean this is a was gonna be
a while there's a little there's stuff
to do up here I'm here for a second
piano something strange about I'm seeing
things child gave me a present the arm
is a sign of the child's trust down
under this happiness
alright oh no a child and [ __ ] all right
I'm on the next ultimate sweet alright
stop with the spoilers there's a lantern
I'll be back oh wait hold on okay cool
bubble now we can yeah alright so you've
kind of already surmised that you need a
lantern to balance that out so where'd
you see a lantern last I played this
very small part I remember a part of
this cuz I played this in VR just a
little part of this you got the lantern
in the demo
yeah for a GameSpot video I know I know
you're talking about I was I was in that
video but
all right I don't know what I where did
I find a lantern well that's what I'm
telling you was last time you saw one Oh
Marguerite
yeah she's holding it oh she died look
at the lantern she took it yeah a long
spider arm did she yes I was trying to
get you to look at it no I don't want to
look all right the next on the
penultimate resinous bugs I made a bug
she is a bug
[Music]